my name is Paula Vick I'm a product
manager of Playkids
it means that in my day to day job I
worked with talk with parents and kids
and families and business people like
the CEO of flake is over here and and
design there is in art in order to get
information to build apps for kids and
I'd like to talk today is about imagine
the app store there's a over a hundred
thousand apps in the App Store's so a
parent decides to download an app and
then he presents the app to to his later
one to the kid and the kid enjoys it and
loves it and you start trying to sell
your product to to to the to the parent
and you get it and there's all this
whole cycle that is happening and after
that after he downloads or she downloads
and the kids enjoys with the app and he
subscribes or she should subscribe to
the app how do you keep these
subscribers engaged to this experience
and so this is what I'd like to talk
today what we learned so far in play
kids on creating subscribers in a
different way than our users but first I
like to give you some background on what
is play kids and to get a sense of the
the size of the problem and this k of
the problem that we're talking about
like it is a the most curated
educational and entertainment platform
for kids in the world we have books and
games and videos through various apps
and you delivering entertainment
education for kids and to get to give
them more sense on how big is it
play kids is watch it over a 150
millions videos a month and kids plays
over a 100 million games a month and as
you can see in our engaging numbers we
have over over a hundred countries that
have already download play kids and we
get they're really enjoying and this
like it's and this is have to do pretty
much what the industry and what's
happening right now last year people
start
getting more time seen and watching
videos and entertainment on their mobile
rather than TV and the same thing is
happening to the kids industry as well
so the all the industry is shifting from
TV and to mobile it's expected you to
deliver a great experience on on mobile
for those cases and but there is a thing
that is not changing that is the needs
of the parents and the needs of the kids
the motivations for them to get together
the motivation for them to download an
app or even to to white a video to get
entertainment art to look for education
okay okay kids in protection of Adagio
says another familiar face
I was a person who came to the change to
entertain men today he conceived of a to
maintain a universal bacon so sugar the
guitars it's involving gota have
maintained the west and Russia we so
important she can present who pass
all are pregnant and potentially be
happening the including what
I didn't know if you if your God is and
and if you got its translation okay and
the thing is she and parents are looking
for ways to kids to play and interact
with a safer place where the kids are
safe and they can learn from playing and
kids otherwise they want a cool place
where they they get superpowers and they
can learn it can paint and create things
and the mix of the things is the base of
play kids what we learn is upon that our
our project is created on based on this
so like is is based on a subscription
model and as first as we launched at
play kids we thought that our life would
be like this so we just started
subscription model and money will come
month after month
and so we discovered that is not as as
easy as it seems because people's cancel
their subscription or there's something
that happened to their subscription that
is cancelled or they uninstall the app
and they don't feel like the app is it's
okay you have to update the app so we
start thinking that whoa it's not only a
thing that you just apply a business
mode you have to to act like a
subscription model and and to do this
you have to think that you are not
creating an app you have to start
thinking about you are creating an
service and and people are paying for
the service month after month so you
have to continuously adding value to the
subscriber so long ago this journey I
created a top list of nine ways that
play kids have evolved with parents with
this with this kind of subscription base
and what we learned so far and how we
are adding value to our subscriber base
the first thing is that Playkids is
moving from an app to a service it means
that we had only one app in 2013 and we
move it to over four apps this year we
moved from only an app that was create
was was given videos and and
games for for the parents for today a
bundle of apps that we can provide
casual games for kids for other kids and
over a thousand books for for kids as
well and communication tool for families
and more and more videos on play kids
and the very innovative thing is that
with just one subscription we can unlock
all the content across all our apps and
this increases a lot the willing to pay
of the parents in this it's as much as
this this is a subscription banner that
we were selling all the apps of play
kids within a same subscription and this
is these are the results just after the
launch we increase it 81 percent in
sales and bringing people to subscribe
to our service by providing a variety of
apps a bundle of apps with the same
subscription and also by creating this
platform we could we could announce
ourselves as a service so we created
featured across all our apps that would
cross promote our apps and then we could
make more better understand for parents
that we were not just an app but a
bundle of apps and by then downloading
one app they could use all the content
other apps as well and one app
complements each other so it it because
more and more are willing to pay
increase in more and more they're
willing to pay for parents and we also
have Lakers catalog that we have a lot
of videos in over 80 28 countries every
country has a different catalog that
will license content and every week
every Friday we launched our nor are not
new episodes or not new videos or new
characters and maintaining this this
kind of this dis launches every every
week there's a lot of work to get done
to to get this and this constant update
discounts the constant look for
prospecting for new characters
characters that kids love
characters that parents care about this
is and disappear dating our services and
up adapts frequently with this created a
sense to the parents that it is the
service is not an app it's not finish it
it's constantly evolved and for us is
very important to have a mix of local
content like getting a vintage in Brazil
Daniel tiger in us with famous and
well-known characters such as Pocoyo or
Backyardigans and and so on everything
that we design on Playkids
is for the amusement of the little ones
if you don't design for the later ones
we are doing our job wrong because they
are going to use it they are going to to
enjoy it they're going to learn things
by using play kids so they are our user
our customers as the parent you have to
convince the parent to keep to keep
subscribing to our service but they have
to to trust us that we created a real
good experience to their little ones
just an example on play kids just one
week before we learn to the version one
while play kids we design it the app to
to have a string to streaming video we
with the string video instead of
download and we bring we brought some
kids to the office and we gave them the
app for them to interact with and we we
did all the setup I don't know if you
already have a usability test with kids
but nothing happens as we wait you
expected we go about this setup and we
brought the kids and and they tap to tie
the video and the spinner loading the
kids just but the tablet away info and
start playing with another toy so by
that moment we know we have to design
with the kid in mind so we just one week
before launching we we said we're not
going to have a string as the full
version as a standard of play kids we
are going to have the download and while
we are downloading we created games so
kids could watch videos what why should
they while they they download a video
they can play play some games and they
come back and and while the videos when
is finished and so on so we designed for
kids and every little detail is very
important for them they expect
everything to be interactive and
everything I've ever little detail play
kids is you can tap and you expect
animation and and yet up in the end of
day if you're not creating a good
product a good toy for the kids why
would the parent care about it if the
kids don't like it why someone would buy
it we also have learned during out the
way that some themes that kids likes
such as music telling about ABC songs
that tell telling about basic steps and
learning basic things and some craft
classes learning how to fold a origami
or something like that and some some
animal songs that would place some
animals in some topics like bullying or
lying and something like that so we
learn it with our data and then what
when was some test what kids will would
love to see and we started creating our
own content and we brought this to the
platform so we brought it to the play
kids so parents could see that there's
someone behind this thinking about how
to well treat our kids and this is
adding value to the platform as well and
we have over 50 episodes for our
original content with over a hundred
million views already
and just for compression what you
understood is that by understanding the
kids and using some metrics we could
create some episodes that were engaging
more kids were watching more and more
and more than some other ones like this
place you can compare ABC episode with
the back backyard young ones
kids were watching more and we're
playing it more and more other thing
that we have a target here already is a
greatest special collections and this is
very important that cross all our apps
our books apps has special collections
for special dates such as the Halloween
or the Easter back to school or summer
and and our lake kids TV app has some
special train cars that have some videos
for the states and this is really
important because kids they're in the
school or they're have some friends and
they're talking about the things so what
is your custom for Halloween oh we're
going back to school and this is a real
link from the offline world to the
online world so when a kid sees it she
likes it she likes it and and the parent
expect us as well we also adapt our icon
to the special date edge which as we
talked before actually we talked a lot
about icons today is a lesson on this
this other thing that we do is social
media bus ever new lounge that we have
every new episode or every new feature
we try to push on the channels that
reach the parents for the parents know
that we are caring about it
updating bringing content and making
their service alive so they're investing
money every month on it and we're
telling them that you are in a safe
place we're creating great app for kids
and the service is evolving we treat our
subscribers as well in a different way
we have a really detailed customer
journey and we to sum up we have four
four states here that when someone
enters on Playkids is a new user and
then we give us seven day free trials so
the user can try split-- kids for free
and then he becomes a she becomes an
active subscriber and then if she
cancels or have some hero or and the MC
if she turns we call this user a churn
in each of this phase we have a
different message through a different
channel or we send emails telling about
the the subscriptions over or during the
period we send emails telling what's
going on and what's new and play kids or
we send a push notification sound
there's some billing problem and so on
so this is very important because this
is a way to recover
but that has churned it and you have to
reconvince parents dip for for them to
to go back to to the service and it's a
good way also to to make parents know
that you are evolving the product so the
app is the channel for the kid and you
have to think and figure out ways to
reach the parents and outside we also
run a lot of eye contests and as we
talked to today we have to do some
experiments because it drives a lot of
results the last one is the most sexual
icon ever imply kit it drove a lot of a
lot of traction a lot of a user
downloads and we use the Google
developer console experience to try
these new things we also try and some
some screenshots experiments to see
which message conveys better to the
parent compared to other one well what
should be the two first screenshots of
the store why should read the
description what should we be the icon
so we can test it and then as we learn
it we can repaint we can spread this
into all the platforms as well and the
bottom line of elders is parents care a
lot of on what their kids are playing
what their kids are learning from
playing and and the first thing that we
learn is that you have to design for
kids it's mandatory you have to create a
great product with great content that
makes sense for kids and then we have to
keep your service always updated and
there's a difference from thinking of
app and fruit and thinking of service
you have to think that your app is a way
to communicate within your service as
you have this in mind you can reach
parents in another way so you can keep
communicate
properly within and show out the value
of your of your product and making
various constant updates as well make it
looks local with local content and an
increase in localization as well and all
the things that fills the content feel
local like if you use Playkids in Brazil
it looks like there's a Brazilian app
but if you use in the US there's a
voiceover in in English there's all the
counters very now in u.s. if we go to
Spain it's all in Spanish and it has all
the voiceovers all the characters
speaking Spanish and and so on and you
have to properly communicate with the
parent you have to send a right message
to the right estate of the user
engagement it's this does not make sense
you to change a message to convince a
parent to subscribe to a service if it
is already or she's already super
scriber
and you have to put your own personality
in the service or by creating our own
content like we did we created our own
characters we created our own shows and
we put it on TV but parents always
expect their kids learn from what
they're doing and they are very proud on
on this and so these are some of the
points that were working on play kids to
make ah to make more clear to parents
that we are service and that our service
is always being updated so I think I
hope this can be useful for you we
learned a lot within the journey and
keep creating get great apps for kids
and keep making them smile so thank you